[Musique]
marie marie pierre jean séguin bonjour
bonjour merci d'être à nouveau sur le
plateau de tv se sont dits gîte
poursuivi qu'on va entièrement vous
consacrez vous êtes yvelinoise et vous
êtes déjà venu nous voir il ya quelques
mois pour un premier livre qui
s'intitule est comment qui s'intitulait
la voix joue fine cholet we choose la
voie du feng shui voilà on voit sa
couverture vous ne vous en aviez donc
parler est la raison de votre présence
aujourd'hui c'est que vous sortez un
nouveau livre qui s'appelle osé
s'accomplir 12 clés pour être soi alors
c'est un vaste programme pour ceux qui
ne vous connaissent pas on va déjà
j'aimerais déjà que vous nous parler de
votre travail en quelques mots quelques
qu'est ce que vous faites dans la vie
madame alors on peut dire que depuis
plus d'une plus de vingt ans maintenant
je suis dans un dans un travail
d'accompagnement des personnes souvent
de consultation et j'utilise toute une
palette de techniques qui appartiennent
à l'énergétique chinoise met notamment
en me centrant sur la question toujours
du bon moment et du lieu pour faire les
choses être oui à la bonne place et au
bon moment pour agir et pour que
l'action porte ses fruits
ouais et donc ça c'est la trame de mon
travail
et là ce livre me centre plus sur
l'individu et sa posture d'accord alors
pourquoi avoir écrit ce livre c'est pour
tous les gens qui n'auront pas la chance
de vous consulter
absolument oui absolument parce que ce
livre permet on va dire que mon objectif
il est l'autonomie de la personne la
possibilité de d'utiliser des outils qui
sont absolument simple quotidien au
service d'une d'une mise en cohérence de
ce que nous sommes et aux services de
soin d'accord parce que vous partez du
postulat qu'on a en soi
de quoi accomplir
ce qu'on a envie d'accomplir hé bé oui
je pars je pars postulat moi je dirais
je pars d'une réalité c'est que nous
naissons tous chacun équipé d'une d'une
palette je reprends ce mou de talent il
ya et je distingue ceux qui à voir avec
l'inné et l'acquis
certaines personnes sont plus capables
ou plus naturellement capable d'être au
service d'une la communication des
équipes
certaines ont davantage besoin que
d'autres de mètres en extérieur
d'accord après vous dire que la personne
soit consciente de ses talents a
toujours rêver non plus je pense que
nous sommes et j'appelle j'appelle ceux
qui pourraient être pour d'autres des
qualités j'appelle ça des talents donc
le l'éducation la société notre manière
de vivre à tendance et c'est aussi une
bonne chose à nous emmener sur des voies
où nous avons à acquérir des compétences
nous avons à acquérir des connaissances
et donc du coup on se retrouve souvent
enfin moi je le vois dans l'intimité des
consultations on se retrouve souvent
avec une situation où la personne a un
petit peu oublié ce qu'il a fait
vraiment vibrer au profit de l'exercice
de compétences qu'elle a acquise mais
qui sont peut-être pas véritablement au
service de son plein rayonne ce qui
l'animent de ce qui l'animé de ce qu'est
la personne d'accord je comprends bon
maintenant que c'est dit on va parler du
livre est un
alors il est un peu particulier ce livre
il est structuré d'une façon
particulière et
donc osé s'accomplir 12 pieds pour être
soi donc on va parler déjà du mode
d'emploi si vous voulez bien comment
l'utiliser il ya d'ailleurs une parade
quelques pages qui sont libres mode
d'emploi il ya une page au début ce
livre propose 12 clé
on pourra dire d'où ce concept douche
posture à considérer éventuellement à
travailler ou à accueillir chacune au
service d'un alignement de nous-mêmes
avec nous mêmes donc on peut le livre on
peut le lire
pardon comme du début jusqu'à la fin de
manière le maire comme un roman ou alors
on peut se repérer dans une liste de
deux mots clés de problématiques de
symptômes qui vous renvoie à la posture
ou au chapitre qui est le plus en phase
avec ce que vous avez à travailler voilà
je dirais que je on peut le comparer à
presque un chemin de pèlerinage que nous
n'avons pas besoin de faire du début
jusqu'à la fin
on ne peut faire qu'une étape du chemin
d'ailleurs on va essayer de l'ouvrir un
peu au hasard ça te met de voir ce qu'on
tombe surtout la première fois ce qu'il
n'y a pas de hasard
alors ça c'est une autre histoire qui
nous prendrait beaucoup donné mais je ne
suis pas sûr que le hasard existe mais
ce livre est aussi content si pour
apporter pour faire de la place à
l'impalpable le dernier chapitre
s'appelle accepté l'aide du ciel chinois
est donc la première fois que vous
l'aurez entre les mains l'ouvrir
n'importe où et voir où ils vous mène
pourrait bien être en résonance avec ce
que vous traversez à ce moment là oui
c'est qu'on en a besoin
ouais au moment précis et laissez-vous à
l'arrêt ou pas bon ça voilà ensuite
alors vous avez une liste de symptômes
de se dire notre questionnement
questionnements qui vous renvoie à une
des douze clé ouais c'est ce que vous
m'avez dit voilà donc vous conseillez
finalement de parcourir cette liste et
de voir ce qui nous ce qui nous touche
way est assez rigolo tu mens ça ne se
dit pas bizarrement bas on va
allez souvent sur la même clé troisième
tome différents vont vous amener à la
même clé oui parce que ce que j'ai
cherché à faire d'abord c'est de de
donner la place à la personne qui me
consultent qu'il a qui va lire cet
ouvrage dont il est question n'ont pas
de partie il est question de partir de
ce que vous êtes et d'aller vers une
lecture qui va apporter des réponses des
exercices
voilà des histoires et des images alors
quelques exemples de clés on a le
problème de la présence on a le vent moi
je mets problème c'est pas le mont au
problème une place pour chaque chose
comme vous disiez l'inné et l'acquis
l'importance du vide
tout ça ce sont des grêlons terre du
plein la bouche avant de nous avant de
nous prendre la tête sur tout ce que
nous n'avons pas encore faisons un
inventaire de tout ce qui a déjà été
accompli parce qu'on a tendance dans
cette pensée occidentale un peu linéaire
très centrées sur la volonté sur
l'effort de cavaler beaucoup et de ne
pas mesurer que le fait d'avoir la
chance d'ouvrir une fenêtre le matin et
d'entendre éventuellement des l'cie un
oiseau fait partie de la qualité de la
vie qui est nourrie fiers de ce que nous
cela va être attentif aux petites choses
qui nous font du bien
oui aussi parce que c'est d'ailleurs le
meilleur moyen d'accomplir de grandes
choses parce que plusieurs petites
choses fait les unes après les autres de
manière régulière et systématique va
vous permettre de gravir une montagne
qui autrement paraître insurmontable et
je me permets aller ne vient me vient ce
que j'ai finalement souvent et j'ai
conscience de caractériser un petit peu
donc d'un côté des personnes qui peuvent
être mois dans des moments d'agacement
des personnes qui vont avoir le
sentiment de ne jamais pouvoir arriver à
quoi que ce soit et de l'autre des
moments où nous nous avons l'illusion de
pouvoir tout faire partout tout tient ça
roule ça paye
à côté cette illusion de force va amener
à des frustrations qui peuvent nous
remettre en cause parce que si je
m'imagine que je peux être absolument
efficace partout tout le temps sans
jamais m'arrêter je vais me fatiguer où
je vais rencontrer un obstacle un qui
est là potentiellement la source d'une
remise en cause
mais si de l'autre côté je crois ce qui
m'a été dit à l'école non par ma famille
ou par les codes sociaux et que je n'ai
pas de place pour faire vraiment ce que
je veux on se retrouve dans des extrêmes
qui n'ont pas de sens
mon travail c'est un travail de
repositionnement au milieu de ces
extrêmes d'accord parce qu'il ya
toujours une petite chose que vous
pouvez quand même faire si elle est
alignée avec ce que vous êtes
par exemple vous êtes dans un boulot qui
ne vous convient pas dans une situation
qui est difficile
vous avez quand même la possibilité de
faire le tour du pâté de maison même si
c'est trois minutes de plus pour rentrer
chez vous si ça vous fait passer devant
un fleuriste qui vous fait qui vous fait
du bien pour moi je suis l'avocate des
petites choses qui multipliait quand
elles sont au service de ce que vous
êtes viennent alimenter ce que c'est ça
mon objectif
votre vitalité une personne qui est en
en en cohérence et en alignement avec
elle-même présence à l est et en
conscience de ce qu'est la autour d'elle
va gagner en force de vitalité et c'est
ça qui des pousses qui qui repoussent
les montagnes c'est ça qui permet de
bouger ce et l'aura de la personne il va
faire que le magasin est fermé est en
train de fermer
elle arrive on va la laisser rentrer
quand même c'est ça qui permet qu'un
coup de fil de plus quand rien n'avance
tout d'un coup va quand même pouvoir
débloquer une situation
donc je suis au service d'une résilience
mais mais mais surtout au service du
retour de la joie dans nos quotidiens
mais oui mais tu sourire bah oui bien
sûr bref qu'est ce que ça veut dire être
soit être en quelques mots rappelant
quelques sets ça ça veut dire
à voir dès le réveil une grande envie de
commencer sa journée
parce que ce que vous allez déployée est
en résonance avec ce que vous êtes
même si ça peut vous paraître une toute
petite chose y'a pas de petites villes
n'y a pas de grande vie chaque être
content
et dans votre livre que vous qui est
passionnant d'ailleurs avoir le choix
d'équilibrer sa destinée c'est une
phrase qui m'a qui m'a sauté aux yeux
c'est cette sortir d'un discours qui
nous aura été collé sur le dos de ceux
que nous ne sommes pas nous ne sommes
pas nous ne sommes pas bons nous sommes
nuls c'est d'arriver par notre posture à
dégager suffisamment de terrains pour
profiter de ce que nous sommes d'accord
alors dans ce livre il ya des exemples
concrets ouais beaucoup des voix là
c'est très vivant et en plus à chaque
clé vous donnez des exercices très très
facile quelquefois très simple c'est la
répétition qui font qu'ils vont agir oui
ici et ce sont je veux signaler que tous
ces exercices sont pas des exercices
théoriques
ils sont simples à mettre en place ils
ne sont absolument pas coûteux et ils
sont véritablement issus de 25 ans de
pratique d'accompagnement quotidien
voilà donc ils sont mis au service de
chacun et mon objectif c'est que les
personnes seules et se les approprient
largement et les diffusent d'année dans
une période où nous sommes là pour
partager
pour avancer il faut sortir de ces silos
ou nous gardons chacun pour soi nos
bonnes recettes d'accord donnons un
donne aux données oui je pense que que
skins et qui parfois n'est pas entendu
c'est que lorsque vous avez le sentiment
qu'on ne vous de ne pas suffisamment
recevoir prenez-vous par la main et
donnait on vous invite pas à dîner
inviter quelqu'un d'accord et ça remet
les choses en route
oui et ça redémarre et après on dira que
c est magique où ce sont des
coïncidences mai
donc moi je suis au service de ces
coïncidences heureuses qui
réintroduisent du vertueux dans une vie
qui par moment et bien et bien triste
tout est bien terrifiante à l'heure
actuelle on sait pas vers où on va bien
sûr donc recentrons nous sur ce qui
alimente notre être ok mais à écouter
grâce à ce livre on devrait y arriver
parce que c'est clair c'est agréable à
lire ces joyeux aussi et c'est utile
franchement donc marie-pierre un grand
merci
c'est un livre qui se suffit à lui-même
assez une boîte à outils oui puis qu'on
peut relire on peut y revenir
il ya peu d'espoir oui oui on va le
puits le cas merci à partager merci
marie pia j'espère à bientôt pour jamais
un troisième livre on sait jamais voilà
mes sentiments les cadets seeger a très
vite
[Musique]